fiona is with us in Washington hi Kiana
how are you hi Dave I'm well how are you
better than I deserve what's up well we
are ready to sacrifice deeply to make up
for the stupid mistakes we've made but
we have a what would Dave do question
and that question is whether we should
sell our house to cut our debt snowball
from 10 years down to three years okay
how much debt do you have not counting
your home five hundred and forty six
hundred thousand dollars five hundred
thousand dollars yes um what pray tale
hmm well your question should be who's
the doctor a lawyer and I am a lawyer
and so three hundred and forty-seven
thousand of that is student loans okay
and what's the rest of it we have forty
five thousand on cars about twenty seven
thousand on a HELOC twenty-eight
thousand for a 401k loan and the
remainder is just consumer debt
what's your household income i am
self-employed so it ranges between one
hundred and sixty to a hundred and
eighty five thousand right now my law
firm is young so hopefully that will go
up but that's about where we're at
what's he make he makes about 135,000
and that goes up every year as well okay
you have a three hundred thousand dollar
income no that's so the 162 185 is our
combined all right now oh what I've
projected to go up over two hundred okay
so let's say you have two hundred
thousand dollar income why does it take
ten years to pay this off just working
through the debt snowball with the
amount that goes out for minimums every
month or two hundred you're gonna pay 50
a year
that's where the calculation is that
running it through Excel I mean
hopefully it would be more than that but
that's our lifestyles older cars yet the
cars are on the chopping block to go and
that'll impact it but they're not the
highest debts the biggest debt fir
there's something wrong with your
calculations because I don't understand
why I'm making 200k is only paying off
50k a year because my student loan one
of them is it's all run so it is at the
very end of the debt snowball and we're
not paying anything on it now the
interest accruing on it is substantial
and that's part of what's delaying it
but we have significantly cut our line
as well as your homework health care is
expensive
what's your homework and our poker would
list it at about 5:45 and what do you
owe on it
407 I'd sell the cars now and I'd fight
this for one year and see where you are
and if you still feel like it's going to
be nine more years after that
yes I'd sell the house I don't think
it's going to be nine years and I don't
know I don't know what I don't know I
don't know what the curb on your income
will be there's nothing lost by doing
that because the house will go up in
value during that time in your market
and so you're gonna make some more money
during this coming year while you try
this but I think you're in the first
three months of doing this whole thing
aren't you about four and a half yeah
okay so that's uh yeah you're young to
it and so what happens is is you almost
go like through the stages of grief in a
sense and that's how can tell kind of
where you are is the first thing that
happens is you have an oh crap moment
you go oh my god what is all we gonna do
with all this thing you how can I have a
hopeful moment and you go oh I think we
can do this and then you write it all
down and you have another oh crap moment
right and that's kind of where you are
right now when you really get into the
grind of it it's like dadgum this is
gonna take forever and that's what
that's what brought the
your willingness to sell the house
indicates that you guys are probably
willing to sacrifice in lots of
different areas and I think a year of
that with a tight budget working on
every dollar the two of you working
together doing everything you can to get
your income up as fast and as far as you
can I think that's going to take you
further than anything else and so let's
see we're eight what a year brings if
next spring when the weather breaks you
don't feel good you still your traction
is not where you think it's going to be
you're not going to zoom zoom and you
want to put the house on the market I
wouldn't blame you but I always sell the
house last I'll sell a car in about 30
seconds but I always sell the house last
it's very expensive emotionally and
financially to move physically draining
to move everything in like that
so yep yeah absolutely absolutely I'd
give it a year and let's see where you
are Wow
you got a mess but the good news is
you're smart and you got a big shovel so
you just have to shovel awhile I think
you'll get there I know you'll get there
if you stay with it